and this is a car jumping the daytona
beach bridge
let's go let's go
if you can't see and you can't see it
because this is verbally for some of you
they have basically
they have a bridge that closes
one of those closing bridges and
sometimes it's by like a river
you know i grew up for a while over
there on a chewfunctor river
down there i'm in saint tammany parish
louisiana and
they said that it got its name because
the chef de indians
named it and they got their name because
one of them had taken a large rock and
thrown it into some water
river multiple
water and that's the sound it made when
it went in
and i always thought man that how
fascinating is that
how much closer to the earth
can you be than to be the octave or the
the the audio remnant
of the sound of a rock going into water
i mean damn
you on mother nature's tit baby
you doing full milk
and so i always thought that was
fascinating that the rock had made
when they threw it in the water and said
that's what they named their tribe but
anyway they had one of these bridges
where rich people
it would either every half hour the
bridge would open for boats to go
through
on weekends and every hour on weekdays
so if you were driving you had to stop
and wait it was a couple minutes
and then there was rumor that rich
people could get through whenever they
wanted
so i always hated that but
god always this person in the video
speeds through the little candy cane
thing that tells you to stop
you know the little red and white stick
or whatever the stop stick
this dude blasts right through it and
then the ramp is going up so it's
already the road is separated the ramps
are going up on both sides the bridges
and this guy jumps the first one and
lands on the second one
i mean it's not a far jump but
i'll be damn if it isn't damn amazing
and he makes it
i mean it's just starting to separate
he just right through bam he made
air he had about almost a full second of
air
so amen to that guy
and maybe that's where we're heading
where people start to do things
themselves more
you know what i'm late for work oh well
you know that's one thing i worry about
the the the fabric of our
society being eroded sometimes and
and i'm not saying i'm right with some
of my speculations i'm just
i don't know over this whole thing it
started to feel like it doesn't matter
what month it is it doesn't matter what
the holidays are it's all
i don't know some of that's just felt
kind of defeating and
and i know there's ways to battle
against that i'm not saying that i'm
defeated
or that we should feel defeated but some
of those feelings have been adding i
think to
just to me not feeling good but um
anyway uh
but maybe that's what really people just
creating new pathways baby
creating new pathways saying look this
is how we do it now if you want to make
the jump
if you want to be that bad boy that
daytona beach bridge
buster then get out there because this
dude
it's a wild it's a wild trip
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one